un bouleversement politique pour nevers
et la nièvre depuis les années 60 le
département avait toujours entretenu une
présence socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale hier ce sont pourtant deux
députés de la république en marche qui
ont été élus c'est l'évolution des
sciences de la vie des choses des
attentes des gens plein de choses c'est
un peu dommage c'est un peu dommage
c'est vrai humour les traditions doivent
être peuvent être changées peuvent être
changées mais c'est dommage dans le sens
où il ya moins de combats il faut
défendre des choses changent et voilà
c'est ce qui s'est produit ici le
socialisme était pourtant ancrée du
morvan terre d'élection de françois
mitterrand jusqu'à nevers fief de pierre
bérégovoy
mais depuis trois ans les avertissements
se sont multipliées perte de nevers
déroute de benoît hamon la
présidentielle en passant par les
ralliements d'élus ps à emmanuel macron
c'est une page qui se tourne c'est c'est
un cycle qui se qui se termine j'ai
envie de dire c'est pas forcément non
plus un bouleversement politique dans la
mesure où la république en marche est
pas non plus un parti d'opposition
traditionnels la nièvre at a basculé à
droite comme peuvent le dire un certain
nombre de commentateurs gaëtan gorce
éliminé dès le premier tour christian
paul battu hier les figures locales sont
mises de côté mais le ps conservera les
commandes du département jusqu'en 2021
et ses élus veulent croire qu'il saura
se réinventer aujourd'hui tout est
questionné va nous falloir repenser
effectivement et retrouver les bons
compromis entre les différents enjeux de
société économiques écologiques et
sociaux etc et retrouver la manière de
réintégrer dans le jeu politique
la population s'il n'est pas encore rayé
de la carte nivernaise le parti
socialiste a vu en quelques années son
héritage ébranlé
et la dynamique pourrait encore se
poursuivre dès les élections
sénatoriales au mois de septembre